Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
It's great to welcome to the program today,
Caleb Kane, who runs the youtube channel.
Farah Day speaks, he's [inaudible]
involved in de radicalizing young people who
get involved in the far right and is actually
the subject of the recent New York Times article,
the making of a youtube radical by Kevin Reuss,
which has gotten a lot of attention.
Uh, Caleb, great to talk to you.
I'm looking forward to this.
Yeah, thank you David.
And thank you for having me on.
So first things first, I mean, how did the
New York Times even find you and decide that
you would be the good subject of an article
about radicalization and deradicalization?
Well when I'm, when I first put the video
out, I never expected it to go that viral,
but I, what I think happened was I went to
Twitter and I was basically, I was basically
trying to market the video a little bit and
I was talking to a lot of people on there
and just like going through and explaining
old ideas that I had and it seemed like a
lot of people were kind of interested by that.
They'd never had someone come out and do that
before.
And at some point, I remember Christian Piccolo
Leni messaged me and he was like, hey man,
are you going to put out a video on all this?
And I'm like, yeah.
And he's like, well, let me know when you
do.
My theory is that they retweeted that stuff
and that's why it got so viral.
I also shared it in some gaming discord servers
and destiny watched it on history.
But I imagined that the New York Times probably
just found it through those channels on Twitter
or I don't know how exactly they found the
video, but I was just going through my email
one day and I had an email from Kevin.
I had a lot of emails from a lot of journalists
at that time.
But, uh, the New York Times is the one that
I went with for the exclusive.
Yeah,
well not so for people who are not familiar
with your story, you became radicalized to
the far right, heavily influenced by some
of these echo chamber algorithm, recommended
rabbit holes that exist on online.
Can you talk about sort of what your life
situation was at the beginning of this?
In other words, because with so often radicalization
goes hand in hand with certain particular
life circumstances at the time that someone
is vulnerable to that radicalization.
So what was going on in your life when you
started to get pulled into this rabbit hole?
Yeah.
So just the brief summary is I come from like
a kind of a lower middle class, not even the
middle class, like an upper lower class background.
And so I didn't have a lot of money.
I a failed out of college due to like depression
and then I hopped around a little bit but
then I ended up back at home in West Virginia
and at my grandfather's house and it was really
just really depressed and beaten up.
And I had been told in high school that I
was Bryant, that I was going places that I
was going to do all these great things and
then none of that stuff happened and quite
the opposite happened.
And I was so depressed that like I was literally
laying in bed all day, only getting up to
use the bathroom and eat and I went to youtube
to try to fix myself off basically.
And when you go to youtube to fix yourself,
what is the first thing you start searching
for that seems like it might be useful to
you in the circumstances you were in?
Well, I had found a game streamer that I'd
used to watch in high school.
He goes by the channel, a theme wins.
And he had started doing all these neuroscience
videos.
He did this documentary called God is in the
neurons.
And I watched that.
And then I started like doing more research
on consciousness, on, uh, neuroscience, self-help.
And I mean, once the algorithm filled up,
I was just clicking thumbnails and it was
from there that I found, um, the CR, the content
creator, Stefan Molyneux that I would later
find.
And so you start at the time, you're not yet
familiar with Stefan Molyneux, but you're
pulled in to some of his content based on
the recommendations from the algorithm.
And then what is it that starts to happen
in your mind when you start consuming his
content?
So, uh, first, um, he did give me some tangental
benefits, right?
So like, uh, I've started caring more about
like personal responsibility.
I started caring more about honesty, but then
like at the same time I was also picking up
a lot of these political ideas that he had.
And in my mind, the way, the way that he framed
it and the way that I absorbed it was that
the political ideologies and the self-help
went hand in hand.
That being a traditional conservative was
like the way you had to go if you wanted to
be happy and if you wanted to like have this
actualize the life that liberalism was like
this failed ideology and you were just going
to have casual sex and be depressed perpetually.
And uh, so it melted.
Well, he welded those two things together
and I just absorbed all of it.
That's super interesting because that's been
one of my critiques of Jordan Peterson, which
is that the self help type stuff is both relatively
harmless and arguably mildly positive.
And it also is quite uncontroversial and unoriginal
in a sense.
But the problem is when people, uh, see that
content as invariably connected to the more
political content that Jordan Peterson is
putting out there, which often is not even
labeled as political, but it gets to the heart
of politics about individualism and egalitarianism
and responsibility and all of these other
things.
That's the danger that sometimes the cell
help is relatively innocuous, but it is indistinguishable
from the politics, at least in the minds of
a lot of the young people that start getting
sucked into this stuff.
And if I hear you correctly, you're, you're
sort of describing a similar mechanism.
Yeah.
And I mean, I like
Jordan Peterson too, and I found him, um,
for the same reasons.
I mean, I guess the way I would put it is
like, it's like the sugar that helps that
red pill go down, right?
Um, so they've got to have a selling point.
I like to think of it from like a marketing
perspective.
So there's gotta be like a hook to draw you
in.
So let's continue down the rabbit hole you
get into Stefan Molyneux, and then where does
the interest go next?
Um, it's hard to tell.
Um, I went to my algorithm and it looks like
what happened and what I remember happening
is it was weird.
So Molyneux I would put like in the old light
category, which is pretty far to the right
in terms of like the center, but I kind of
found Steven Crowder in like a lot of the
conservatives next.
And like I found Ruben and I was kind of watching
a lot of those guys.
I was listening to a lot of stuff about free,
I guess I found it because of like the libertarianism
and stuff, the free market economics and that's
why I was listening to them.
And so I went from being like a libertarian
to a conservative.
And then from listening to them, I started
later finding content creators like Lauren
southern and Gavin.
And then I kind of came full circle and was
listening to Steph again.
Uh, and that was when I kind of drifted into
that alt light civic, what they would call
civic nationalism into that sort of category.
And is part of what was going on.
I'm curious like how established your political
beliefs were before all of this started because
what pulled you into this from the beginning
was actually recognizing that you weren't
happy with your life circumstances and you
wanted to improve them.
You said fix yourself at the beginning of
our interview.
How entrenched were your political beliefs
in general at the time
when I went to the right or before that
for when you first started getting into youtubers
and eventually got to some of the more political
ones, did you identify politically as someone
on the left or were you relatively apolitical?
Yeah, I mean I did.
I guess I wasn't very well read politically,
but I was very much like I went to school
when I first went to school.
When I first went to college, I wanted to
work on helping the environment.
So I did civil engineering and I intended
to transition to environmental engineering
after I got to the, the next tier of school,
I passed the community college.
Um, so I was big into that.
I was also really socially liberal, so I was
really politically outspoken.
I would get in a lot of arguments with my
Republican family.
Uh, but looking back I guess it wasn't super
well read and that's why I even fell into
that stuff in the first place.
So as this continues, how long would you say
that you were deeply entrenched in right-wing
beliefs during this phase that you were consuming
all of this content?
Well, it was a dip going in and then kind
of a valley and then it was like a dip.
You're going to have a rise coming out.
Uh, meaning I didn't just like find contra
points in destiny and become a liberal or
something.
So I would say like four and a half to five
years that I was consuming that content and
seriously thinking it.
And during that time were you acting, were
you an activist for these beliefs in other
areas of your life or, or was it mostly limited?
Limited to consuming the content online?
It was mostly limited to consuming content,
but like anytime I had an opportunity, my
day to day life, so like any of my relationships
and I've chased off a lot of friends this
way, I alienated a lot of people and I noticed
that people didn't want to talk politics with
me.
Uh, so I had a fiance at the time that they
talked about in the article.
Um, I would push my beliefs on her a lot.
I would also do like a lot of psychoanalyzing
on her cause that's like what Steph kind of
taught me to do.
Um, so I would do that with her.
And then she had a brother in law that I would
like argue with and he just got to the point
where he wouldn't discuss that stuff with
me.
Uh, so it was mostly just people in my personal
life that I would quote unquote try to red
pill.
So it sounds like in a few ways, this hurt
relationships in your sort of real life, but
to get back to, you know, you said your initial
goal at the beginning was again to improve
your life other than getting you into political
beliefs that you now realize are problematic
and no longer follow.
Did consuming this content improve your life
in any other measurable ways?
I mean, I took on a lot of the values that
Steph purported to hold, right?
So like honesty, like after that, I've always
been a pretty honest person, but after that
I like very much try to stick with that.
I do.
I started thinking about personal responsibility
in a way that I never really thought about
it before.
I mean to me though, these aren't things that
I needed to become a right wing to figure
out though.
But, uh, I guess I could say that those were
some of the positive benefits.
But in other ways, like all in all, it just
alienated me from like a lot of people.
What started to change when the Youtube Algorithm
ultimately led you to a path out of the right
wing beliefs?
Was it one video in particular that you remember
popped up in that algorithm that something
changed in you that maybe made you start looking
for other things?
No.
Nope.
Nothing.
Nothing made me look for anything new and
I would've kept going down that path.
And now that I talk to people further to the
right, I wonder if I would've went into the
national socialists category or not.
I don't know.
Um, but, uh, cause I was just heading down
that trajectory.
So I don't know what would've happened if
I kept going.
It was by chance it was the fact that destiny
did those debates.
Um, I thought that it was the, Lauren southern
was the first video that popped up, but apparently
he did a conversation with Martin Shkreli,
who was somebody that I was interested in
back then.
And so he did a conversation with Martin and
then he did an ironically, he did a conversation
with a theme wins the guy that I mentioned
earlier, and then he did the conversation
with Lauren.
Uh, so it was almost primed to like destiny
a little bit because of those previous conversations.
I thought when he'd had the conversation with
Lauren it was going to be like a nice conversation
cause he had such a conversation with Martin.
I thought he was a right winger.
And then I watched the conversation with Lauren
and he really deconstructed a lot of arguments
that she had on mass immigration, which was
my huge sticking point.
And then after that I just kept watching more
and more destiny videos.
And then I found contra points through destinies
videos because of the algorithm.
Cause she did an interview with destiny and
then I started watching her content.
It wasn't until her content that I found other
people's content before that it was all hidden
behind this like curtain, uh, on Youtube.
And just to make sure the audience knows,
so some of the people you're mentioning, Destiny's
a is a video game streamer who I've interviewed
on the show and is a friend of mine.
His real name is Steve Brunel.
And, and uh, I just saw him in Los Angeles
a couple of weeks ago.
His people might know.
Contra points is a Youtuber, Natalie Winn,
who I've also interviewed on the program,
who's doing really, really great work about
exposing fascism and authoritarianism and,
and a lot of other stuff.
So how long would you say the deprogramming
period lasted sort of like from the first
time, not maybe that you watched a destiny
debate, but when it actually started to reach
you in a way where you were starting to reconsider
your beliefs until you considered yourself
kind of like out of the right wing.
How long was that process?
Well, I found destiny at the beginning of
28 like the end of 2017 beginning of 2018
and then up or, or no?
Yeah.
So it began at the beginning of 2018 so I
guess it took about like a year and a half,
something like that.
And at the endpoint, what do you now, what,
what's your assessment of what it is that
that happened here?
I mean you went in and out both in a sense
as a result of the same youtube algorithm
that on different days is going to recommend
different things to you in a way that it contains
so many variables that it's hard to at first
to even say exactly why it is that things
come up when they come up.
How do you see these, these several years
of your life?
That went one way and then a very different
way.
It's really bizarre.
I mean, even when I was a right wing or I
would sit and think, I was like just a couple
of years ago, I was a lefty.
I'm a right winger now.
This is weird, but I mean they got all the
best arguments.
I guess they're right.
I mean that's what I believed at the time.
I guess it was, it's alienating.
Looking back, I was looking, I was searching
for something.
I was in a dark place and I was searching
for something to get me out of it and I had
found something that I thought got me out
of that.
I also had an addiction to youtube, something
I've had to analyze since then.
There's like a draw, not just to go deeper
into the ideology because there's like an
addiction to that, but also just to consume
more and more content,
which is, which is actually really what the
algorithm is meant to do.
I mean a lot of the conversations that now
are coming up about is youtube bias to the
left or to the right.
And what about their internal employee culture
versus the way they relate to regulation in
the end when it comes to the algorithm, everything
I see continues to suggest to me that it's
an algorithm meant to people watching for
as long as possible, which is what's the most
profitable for youtube period.
Yup.
And that pretty sure that's what youtube said.
The algorithms name is reinforced.
That's the name of the AI.
That is the most dystopian thing I've ever
heard, by the way.
Reinforce, reinforce what like, so yeah, that's,
that's all they care about.
Um, and you know, people talk about their
politics.
Yeah.
Youtube, left-leaning.
Sure.
Uh, it looks like they did do some, I haven't
looked into the project Veritas thing too
much, but it does look like they, uh, they
have a political bias there.
Um, that doesn't surprise me.
Uh, but the thing is, is people, you know,
I've seen people say, well there's majority,
it's a majority lefty content on youtube and
it's not really, if you're counting the, the
late night call, you know, the late night
shows then sure.
But W for a long time when I was in that space
and we used to brag about it, that youtube
was dominated by right-wingers.
It was all right-wing creators that I was
watching.
And even the bread tubers that I found later,
they haven't been around for that long.
Um, I mean, cat black and people like you
have been on youtube for a while, but it's
mostly, it was mostly dominated by the SAR
guns of cards and the, the Mall News and the
southerns and the Gavin's.
And
the other thing also though, Caleb, is that
we have to be able to say, okay, you're doing
a [inaudible].
You're looking at what is the content that's
on youtube and how is it doing?
There's also the reality that a company's
internal culture does not necessarily tell
us as, as a corporate entity what the political
biases are.
I mean, on the one hand, yes, Google has rules
about, uh, diversity and how LGBT people should
be treated.
And it all sounds so lefty, but at the same
time, Google's part of the surveillance industrial
complex and working with government in ways
that, I don't know any progressive that would,
I would say those are progressive values as
an example when it comes to anti-regulation
or quote regulating ourselves as I recently
spoke about with Joe Rogan.
So it's also important when we have those
conversations to really say what is it that
we're assessing when we measure how many left
versus right wing channels as opposed to what
are the corporate priorities of Google or
youtube.
These are all important conversations, but
different ones.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's a good point.
I mean, to me, I think that Google's corporate
priority is just to make money.
Um, and I don't think they're trying to push
people in any particular particular direction.
Um, I just think it's about money
the end of the day, make sure if you have
not read the article in the New York Times
to read it, the making of a youtube radical,
we've been speaking with the subject of that
article, Caleb Kane who runs the youtube channel.
Faraday speaks.
Caleb, really appreciate your time and you
talking to me today and I'm glad you got out
a of a, of the valley as you called it.
Yeah, thanks man.
Yeah, and I, just real quick, uh, what we're
working on right now is we have a discord
server.
It's very experimental, but we're trying to
show idea the other side of these people that
have kind of fallen into this rabbit hole
and to give them support to kind of pull them
out.
And how can people find that?
So you can find that, uh, if honestly if you
go to my youtube videos and go into the link,
there's a link in the description to the discord
channel.
It's called ferret a fan on discord.
But if you just go to any of my youtube videos
at Fairday speaks on youtube, you'll find
the link into the, to the disc
for him, the description of all videos.
All right, thanks so much, Kale.
Thank you David